Our first step is going to be to calculate m, the amount of money that Grant
spends each month. Here are the two important pieces of information that we got
from the question. We can replace fixed costs with 20,000. Since we know that
each wiper set costs $10 to make, and Grant makes n wiper sets, going to have
20,000 plus 10n equaling m. That means we can now take this quantity and replace
it in the spot of m in our equation for p. Since we're subtracting m, we need to
make sure that we're subtracting this entire quantity, both terms. This looks
pretty good right now, but remember you want to replace n here. With the
expression that we found in terms of c which was just negative 200c plus 18,000.
Now, we can finally go through and simplify our equation. This gives us a final
equation for p of, miraculously, negative 200c squared plus 20,000c minus
200,000.